I've already grown a Goethe from this
torture my Stuart squashed under my chin
my beards pointing at heaven
my brains crushed in a caskets my
breasts twist like a harpies my brush
above me all the time gerbils paint so
my face makes a fine floor for droppings
my poor asks trains to work as a
counterweight every gesture I make is
blind and aimless my skin hangs loose
below me my spines all knotted from
folding over itself my painting is dead
I am NOT in the right place I am NOT a
painter would it surprise you if I told
you that these lines were scribed by
none over the Michelangelo painter of
the Sistine Chapel ceiling
we often gaze upon masterpieces so
miraculous as this and imagine it as a
piece born from a desire to create great
art with passion pouring from the
artists every pore Michelangelo in fact
hated his grand epitome of human
creation finding it quite the bore yet
over five million people flock to admire
it every year
Michelangelo loved every minute of its
creation so much so that he wrote the
preceding poem so then why did he do it
well he was being paid by the church and
as we all know for enough money a man
will sell his soul or paint of giant
fresco on the Pope ceiling Eva are just
as plausible a picture paints a thousand
words this well-known idiom reveals the
most important aspect of artwork that it
is potentially the most powerful medium
we have to record and be able to reflect
on history in a visual way today every
relevant and far more often irrelevant
moment of human creation is captured in
photography frequently archived publicly
for the world to view when Apollo 11
landed the first two men on the moon in
it was captured fantastically on film
and broadcast far and wide for all to
see we can all observe in precise detail
what happened in that momentous moment
but until the advent of photography we
had to rely on just two mediums to guide
us through the triumphs and tribulations
of times gone by writing and
illustration when Leonardo da Vinci
invented his flying machine he probably
would have rather lights to make it up
noxious Li gloat filled Instagram post
but he was thankfully resigned to
drawing an impressively detailed yet a
beautifully artistic sketch instead
needless to say writing is a powerful
force but only ours can influence a
nation with a single glance artwork
drops us from the drudgery of our
pixel-perfect period in time and grants
us a wonderfully dynamic perspective on
the events that changed our world
artwork allows us to instantly visualize
moments such as the signing of the
Declaration of Independence the
invention of Gutenberg's printing press
the French Revolution the Protestant
Reformation
the fall of the Roman Empire and that
elusive period during the Middle Ages
when the world was full of murderous
giant rabbits and alike those freakishly
satanic rabbits famous pieces of artwork
aren't always historically accurate
George Washington certainly didn't cross
the Delaware like this and Napoleon
didn't look as fabulous as this whilst
crossing the Alps unfortunately for a
start he would have ridden a mule not a
horse
as Paul della Rush depicted in this far
more realistic envisioning of the event
painted in 1850 but you know what
these inaccuracies don't matter the
purpose of great art is not to provide
an exact recount of the events in
question we have historical textbooks
for that instead art provides are
stylized sometimes idealized version of
Vence that ate our imagination and with
one single glance transports us to that
precious moment in time it is only
through this spectacular visualization
of art that allows it to perforates
popular culture and bring history to the
masses it is not for us to imagine the
ambience of a cafe terrace in southern
France in the late evening of 1888 for
on this van gock has those covers also
in the late 19th century one artists
paintings helped all of Europe visualize
and new worlds and caused mass migration
and thus by no exaggeration
one man's artwork built the American
West
more specifically German American Maine
tur Albert Bierstadt rich vistas of the
Living landscape of the American West
were brought back to London in 1867 and
exhibited to the masses from all over
Europe including a private exhibition
for Queen Victoria so mesmerized by the
adil ik freedom depicted upon these
canvases so beautifully promised was the
vast bounty of the free new world laid
bare to all that British German and
Irish people packed up their lives and
migrated to America in their millions it
has been said that European migration to
the States was fueled by Bierstadt's
arts arts camp and has been used to
mobilize entire nations into mass
hysteria into war into peace or to
simply mobilize them to colonize new
lands art doesn't just change what we do
it changes how we think and what we
think changes the type of images we
prefer to look at psychological studies
have demonstrated how our personalities
are reflected in the type of artwork we
find pleasing to the eye and thus what
we choose to hang on our walls at home
there is a very real unpredictable
positive correlation
between conservatives and highly
representational artwork in other words
people who have a more conservative
outlook on life prefer traditional
artwork artwork that looks like what it
seeks to represent through instance when
19th century Belgium Eugen jaws set out
to paint a man playing a guitar he by
some miracle of humanity ended up
painting a man with a guitar meanwhile
at the same time in France cubist
Georges Braque
attempted their very same feat to paint
a man with guitar yet somehow painted a
tear in the space-time fabric
conversely liberals considerably prefer
abstract art forms such as cubism
surrealism and modern art such as
Bennett Newman's one-man 6 alternatively
known as Blue Square of line down the
middle which recently sold for forty
three point eight million dollars but
this is not nearly as ridiculous as the
artwork not on display at the Museum of
non visible arts you heard that
correctly the Museum of non visible art
is exactly that a gallery of empty rooms
and empty walls each blank wall is
accompanied by a title and description
card that describes the artwork you are
supposedly looking at it's up to your
mind to imagine what the artwork should
look like
good luck I'm sorry but if I paid a
tenner to see the latest blockbuster at
the cinema and I was told I had to
imagine what the film looks like for two
hours because it's a non-visible film
it's reasonable to say I would be beyond
pissed yet most incredible of all this
gallery made a sale in 2011 a woman paid
$10,000 for the piece titled fresh air
in exchange for her 10 fats jeez
she received a card with a description
of the artwork which she could
presumably stick to an empty wall at
home and
to describe to all her family and
friends why there is a gaping white
space in her living room and then
idiotically larger space in her wallet
an art magazine describes this piece
like so are you meet peace only this one
is for sale the air you are purchasing
is like buying an endless tank of oxygen
no matter where you are you always have
the ability to take a breath of the most
delicious clean smelling air the earth
can produce every breath you take it
gives you endless peace and health this
artwork is something to carry with you
if you own it because wherever you are
you can imagine yourself getting the
most beautiful taste of air that is from
the mountaintops or fields from the
ocean side it is an endless supply well
that sold me where's my wallet but how
does art affect us in our modern day to
day lives we see art work everywhere we
go sometimes in our homes doctor's
waiting rooms in the workplace whether
it be a print of a beautiful Renaissance
fresco by Raphael looming luxuriously
behind a receptionist head or one of
those bizarre iana rationalities of
human form placed unaccountably on your
mother's coffee table because she thinks
it had to touch a class to the room even
if we pay little conscious attention to
any of these pieces positioned
throughout our lives they actually do
affect us considerably and the very
presence of art changes the way we think
and behave recent research by exiting
University's School of Psychology
concluded that employees who work in an
office decorated with ours are 17% more
productive than those who work in a
blank office space of a research
conducted by the University of
Westminster found that viewing art for a
small amount of time each day reduces
cortisol stress levels increases our
empathy towards others releases dopamine
increases our critical thinking
abilities by up to 18 percent and it can
also help reduce mental
Austan in the exact same way that
spending time outdoors does so there you
go instead of going outside hang a
picture of a field on your wall a study
in 2014 also found that creating or
viewing arts increases physical
resilience and can actually delay aging
art is inextricably tangled with our
humanity we don't only appreciate it
when it's done well we have an innate
need a desire to create and look at it
when our ancient hunter-gatherer
ancestors crafted tools needed to
survive they took extra time to make
them symmetrical and attractive for no
other reason than it gave them
satisfaction to use aesthetically
pleasing tools rather than ugly ones
also because they had bugger all else to
do throughout modernity in building our
houses and public spaces all
civilizations the world over have spent
huge amounts of extra money time and
manpower to make them visually appealing
in a YouGov poll seventy-seven percent
of respondents said they prefer
traditional architecture with its ornate
beauty over cold contemporary buildings
with their hostile steel and glass
facades the data shows that across the
UK buildings and traditional
architecture and even neo traditional
architecture sell for 15% more than
modern housing London house was built
before the First World War
you know when new builds were actually
still attractive went up in value four
hundred and sixty five percent over the
past 30 years whereas their newer
post-war counterparts well their value
rose by only two hundred and fifty five
percent over the same period people pay
a huge premium for beauty and good
architecture is art why do we pay so
much more for a few details in our
brickwork and around our window frames
because humans are hard-wired to seek
out and derive pleasure from beauty the
research on this is clear and
stance off' living in a beautiful area
amongst beautiful houses which one could
equate to living in a piece of artwork
makes us happier less stressed and
healthier and bringing that beauty into
your home wherever it's a painting that
brings you joy or a sculpture you admire
will only increase these effects so why
don't you seek to bring happiness to
others and change the world by creating
your own art to be admired by all of
society whether your dream is to paint
illustrate stories or comics create
sculptures or work with clay there is
only one place on the internet I would
recommend to help you fulfill these
dreams Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25 thousand classes in
design art illustration and much more
Premium Membership gives you unlimited
access so you can join the classes and
communities that are just right for you
you may want to fuel your curiosity
creativity or even your career whichever
it is Skillshare is the perfect place to
keep you learning and thriving if you
are thinking about picking up fine art
as a new hobby then I highly recommend
the Skillshare course modern watercolor
techniques and beginners level it's
everything you need to get started
if however illustration is more of your
thing then you have to watch ink drawing
techniques brush nib and pen style it's
such a fun and unique course that will
give you a huge headstart Skillshare is
also super affordable an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month over 7 million creators like you
have already joined and for the first
500 of my subscribers to use the link in
the description they will get a free
two-month trial of Skillshare premium
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
this video then consider subscribing to
see more on a regular basis also I'd
like to thank Skillshare for sponsoring
this video don't forget to check them
out the links below